[Music]
you
when chess players start out they of
course learn the rules and how to move
the pieces but after that everyone of
every age can't wait to build tactical
skills so they can chase down and
execute the enemy king and various
colorful very exciting ways to
accomplish this stage one of a well
rounded attacking style calls for the
mastery of a few must know tactical
patterns these patterns will be used
constantly throughout your chess
adventures since they form the
foundation for all your competitive
tactical positional and attacking
operations notice how I tossed
positional in there what in the world
does positional play have to do with
tactical patterns the answer is that
tactics often explode on the scene of
even the most tranquil situations and
you'll win many games by segwaying from
a position imbued with buddha-like
silence to a maelstrom of tactical
madness knowing these patterns is also
key to a good defense this if you if
you're well acquainted with them you'll
see them coming and as a result be able
to avoid the enemy wood chipper that's
heading your way however even the
mention of positional chess upsets a lot
of players who live eat and breathe the
great god attack for them all other
forms of chess are for the faint of
heart
in their minds real men drag down their
prey quickly and violently these people
and there are an enormous amount of them
aren't after improvement to true
understanding they just want to let
their hair down and rip rend and stop
their way to a grand old time and you
know what if this I don't need to be
good I just want to have fun and feel
the adrenaline pour through my veins
philosophy excites you then go for it
it's a perfectly reasonable path to take
when I was 15 years old in San Diego I
occasionally played in the Ville Valo
Chesto chess club I was told that a
seventy year old man named maca si had
just learned how to play and was beating
everyone up with his ferocious style I
watched his games whenever I could and
he was
amazing maxi tried to roll his opponents
off the board before they were even
awake since bishops almost always get
out before the rooks this attacking
maniac would happily trade his
five-point looks for the three point
enemy bishops with the idea that his
bishops would quickly join into the
attack where the enemy rooks would still
be frozen on their launch pads while
Rome burned his logic fascinated me but
the highlight of the show was that his
habit of rubbing his hands together
while mumbling go get the body go get
the body of course that would be illegal
on a modern tournament setting but
imagine the effect that had on his
opponents let's start our first steps to
attacking ma'am by looking at the three
go to tactical punches pins skewers
forks pins and skewers are incredibly
important since they constantly turn up
in all kinds of positions and if you
manage to execute either one of these
deadly weapons the game can if it's a
particularly virulent example and like
that let's have a look at a complete
game that ends in only four moves
because of a pen at first the game
starts out normally efore frees the
bishop frees the queen controls two very
important central squares perfect move
black plays this move the only problem
is the Queen is going to be pulled out
white takes and now the Queen is
vulnerable usually you don't want to
bring your queen out too early because
anything that attacks it will chase it
away the Queen cannot be lost to a
weaker piece so therefore having the
Queen out there it's it's a target white
of course says all right I'm going to
develop a piece and at the same time hit
the Queen so the Queen has to move
normally in this situation the Queen
would just go to a5 or to d6 those two
moves are quite popular however in this
situation Queen c6 and this has been
played thousands of times by beginners
unfortunately Bishop to b5 and some
only the queen is pinned to its king you
can't move away because then you would
hang your King can't do that and if you
leave it there you'll be taken and so
really there's nothing to do and after
Queen takes just Knight takes that wins
the Queen and so after Bishop b5 Black
has no choice but to resign of course a
pin isn't always deadly in fact many
pins are simply temporary annoyances the
game is about even and neither side has
done real damage to the other black
decides to pin White's Knight with
Bishop to g4 so he's threatening this
Knight and if the knight were to move
there goes the rook so this is a pin
however it's no big deal
white can simply block the pin and guard
the knight and everything's okay so
after something like Bishop e2 like we
just did King g7 rook to e1 you still
can't move the knight because now the
Knights pinned to the bishop so white
just moves his rook guarding this and
next move for example let's say black
play something like rook d6 95 and now
the pin is done everything's fine and
the game is even there's nothing wrong
with annoying your opponent but when you
look at our initial example you'll
notice that the pinning Bishop is
threatening something of greater value
than the Bishop namely the enemy Queen
meanwhile in our present example the
pinning Bishop is threatening something
of equal value naming the knight that
means that capturing in our first
example is a winner since you're picking
up a queen for a bishop well in the
second it's just an equal trade three
points for three points again there's
nothing wrong with the second pin but
one is crushing and the other is nothing
more than bothersome though if
bothersome is the best you have then you
should go for it bishops aren't the only
piece that can pin you'll find that
rooks are particularly good at the art
of pinning material is even but black's
knight is pinned to the rook and white
threatens to push his pawn to c4 when
the knight is under it
by two white pieces if that occurred
black would face the loss of the night
which is game ending or the loss of the
rook which is also game ending however
its blacks move so one would think that
he'd be able to come up with something
to save himself but no even with the
move there's no way for black to avoid
material losses the best he can do is
something like King g7 c4 and since
there's this pen and the knight can't
move black has to resign here's another
example of a rook pin material is even
since White has a rook worth five points
but black is a knight and two pawns for
it also worth five points black would be
okay if it was his move but white can
win the game with rook to d1 and once
again we have this horrendous pin he has
to guard it so c6 would be played and
then after efore the Knights a goner
because it can't move because you can't
let your King be taken on this file and
black needs to resign Kings pawns and
Knights can't pin but if rooks and
bishops can then the Queen which has the
combined powers of a rook and Bishop
should be a pinning machine White has an
extra Queen which is worth nine points
but black is hoping to hold on since he
has an extra pawn rook and Knight which
combined is actually also worth nine
points alas this is a hollow dream since
white can create a deadly pin with Queen
to h4 when the knight is attacked and if
it were to move to safety for example by
night to h7 suddenly the Queen takes the
rook so we have this pin one would think
well alright surely he can like guard
the knight in some fashion the problem
is that he can't play f6 to guard it
because this Bishop is pinning that pawn
so the pawn can't do that and if you
were to play Knight II 6 moving the
knight to safety and also guarding
yes this night guards it's rough
unfortunately then white simply captures
the night and if you capture back you're
going to lose the rook and so since
you've lost a whole piece you have to
resign and yet another pin casualty the
skewer is the same as a pin except the
more valuable enemy pieces attacked and
the x-rayed piece is the less valuable
so the pin directly attacks the less
valuable piece while the skewer directly
attacks the more valuable piece in this
position white plays the very tasty
looking Bishop to g5 suddenly the queen
is attacked and when it moves the rook
will die the best that I could do would
be Queen to d4 Bishop takes rook Queen
takes and unfortunately black's going to
lose because he's lost a rook for a
bishop if we reverse the position we'll
have a pin instead of a skewer in this
case after Bishop g5 the weaker piece is
attacked and the stronger one is x-rayed
earlier we looked at a position where
Bishop g4 created an annoying but not
fatal pin you're attacking the weaker
piece x-raying through to the stronger
piece y can simply defend himself if we
reverse the knight and rook we get a
skewer Bishop g4 now it's dot annoying
it's deadly the problem is you do not
want to let your rook be taken by the
bishop you can guard it but then you
lose five points for three
you don't want really to let that happen
however after Bishop g4 how are you
going to get away
if you move your rook to safety you're
going to lose a whole night three points
you can't do that and if you try
something like rook d3 guarding the
knight unfortunately that pawn will just
take you there for this skewer
it's very deadly and white will lose the
game a fork occurs when
one piece attacks two or more enemy
pieces at the same time most people
think of nights when a fork is mentioned
but the fact is that every piece
including pawns and the king can fork a
successful night fork though can be pure
thrilling magic White has a very tasty
choice of two different forks Knight g6
check wonderful you're threatening the
king and you're threatening the rook
that's a very strong move however
there's something even better
Knight to e6 check now you're
threatening the King and you're
threatening the Queen you win a queen
blacks a goner the knight fork was nice
but a family fork something that
everyone dreams of getting is electric
blacks upon up but whites Knight is very
strong on d5 unfortunately for black
it's even stronger on c7 white plays
Knight c7 check and creates a family
fork and you can see why it's a family
for it it hits the king it hits this
rook it hits the a6 rook it hits the
bishop and it also hits the Queen
obviously
after the check is done white will go
for the Queen instead of those other
pieces the game is over black's pawn
down but it doesn't look so bad he has a
lot of pressure on this pawn the bishops
attacking it the rooks attacking it so
blacks thinking alright you know I'm a
pawn down but I'm in the game and I
could probably do pretty well
unfortunately he's not going to do
pretty well after Bishop d5 we have a
fork bishop fork and the bishop hits
this rook and the other rook at the same
time even worse there's no way to guard
either rook in a normal sense in other
words just losing a bishop for a rook
which would be losing but still you
can't even do that you're going to lose
a whole rook here and so because you're
going to lose a whole rook black gives
up no reason to play on a whole rook
down
material is even and black has just
moved his rook to be six attacking the
a6 pawn black was feeling quite
comfortable here until he saw White's
reply rook to c7 this Forks the pawn and
the bishop and wins material after
Bishop to d6 rook takes a 7 and White's
a pawn is very close to becoming a queen
black of course will play on in this
position but ultimately he's going to
lose because that pawn is going to turn
into a queen or at best black would have
to give up his bishop for that pawn
leaving himself a bishop down you may
have noticed that most of the examples
that led to material losses are in many
ways due to one side having too many
undefended pieces that same problem
occurs here after white plays Queen d5
the Queen of course very powerful piece
really shows his clout with that one
move his forked rook on f7 the rook on
a2 and the night at b7 faced with
enormous material loss a rook black
would give up or play on knowing that
his goose is cooked
Black has just checked White's king with
rookie six check looks everything's fine
both sides have a rook black has a
knight white as a bishop one pawn each
looks like a draw however the King Forks
blacks rook and Knight at the same time
there's no way to guard both of them and
suddenly from oh this is an easy draw to
I am doomed because the knight is ready
to fall and once again a fork takes the
opponent down we've seen
Knights Fork we've seen the King Fork
we've seen the Queen Fork we've seen
bishop forks but pawns can also fork
White's pawn in this position
happily moves to d5 suddenly at the same
time it attacks a knight and a rook but
maybe blacks saw this and had an ax
loosen ation he thought okay that's very
threatening but what if I go rook to d6
pinning the pawn because my rook if he
took it took the knight would take
White's rook that's very nice
the problem is that he missed pawn takes
Knight check therefore he can't take the
rook because the Kings in check and
after something like King takes rook
takes King takes White is a bishop up
for one pawn which should be easily
winning after seeing the carnage that
pins skewers and forks rained down on
the enemy position we'll continue with a
very useful but often unappreciated
decoy the idea is to pull the piece away
from an important job often by making
use of a pin or skewer or some other
tactical device leading to doom in
another area or to pull a piece to a
square it doesn't want to be on with
agonizing results for the opponent a
decoy tends to be a bit more complicated
than the other patterns we've looked at
but once you've seen it in action it
will make perfect sense Black has a pawn
and queen for whites Bishop at night I'm
sure he was delighted since 10 points to
6 is nothing to scoff at however the
gleam in White's eye as his hand reached
out to move let black know that
something was up
and after White's Bishop to b5 reality
came crashing down on blacks head the
pin along this diagonal hits the Queen
hits the King and black really has no
choice but to take the bishop
unfortunately Knights e7 check now Forks
the Queen
and King in effect White's Bishop
decoyed the Queen away from the c7
square allowing the fork after Knight c7
check here's another kind of decoy
material is even and no whites battery
along the h1 a a diagonal is directly
aimed at b7 blacks Queen is defending it
so everything's fine
or is it white makes use of a decoy
gobbling up a bishop with rook takes d6
normally that wouldn't be a problem
because the Queen is guarding it however
Queen takes d6 pulls you away from this
key b7 Square allowing Queen takes b7
mate so after rook takes d6 Black has no
good movies just lost a bishop for
nothing and he's not going to survive in
a way one can think of forks skewers and
pins as double attacks since one piece
attacks two at the same time in fact the
main idea of a double attack making two
threats at once is the backbone of the
vast majority of tactical themes here's
a famous example of a pure double attack
White's a piece for upon behind but he
deliberately gave up that piece knowing
that he had a crushing double attack of
course
rook takes c8 check Queen takes c8 does
nothing it just makes it even trade so
you need to find something better
what white did is Queen to c3 now rook
takes c8 check is threatened which wins
a whole rook you can't allow that but
the problem is you also threaten Queen
takes g7 which is mate which is even
worse than losing a rook and faced with
losing a whole rook with check no less
and a mate usually black would give up
unn
the pure double attack the discovered
attack is different and that one piece
doesn't make both threats white makes
use of our old friend the unprotected
enemy piece by sacrificing the bishop
and uncovering attack against blacks
Queen by White's Bishop takes f7 check
you're giving your bishop away
however because he's in check he has to
take it or move out of the way and once
you do that suddenly you notice that the
Queen is left standing there helpless
undefended and white simply chops it off
and wins the game because well he's he's
won black's queen going back to our
initial position you can see blacks
queen was floating around the board
without a defender a normal bishop move
Bishop d3 for example would have led to
an even trade by queen take c2 bishop
take c2 but Bishop takes f7 check left
black helpless due to the whites double
attack against his king and queen I
think you can see why this is called a
discovered attack but these names and
compartments aren't important what
really matters is you understand the
patterns the two big ideas I want you to
walk away with our one noticing
undefended enemy pieces your opponent's
and your own and two being aware of the
power of attacking multiple pieces with
one move train yourself to have warning
bells go off whenever either of these
two things exist sometimes the Bell will
be telling you to watch out there by
using this information defensively and
other times the bells will tell you that
a fun attacking possibility might be as
close as a flick of your wrist
our final blunt-force trama subject is
called efficient Zhuge no I didn't just
sneeze and I didn't make that word up
it's German and it describes an
in-between move one definition is an
unexpected reply tossed in the middle of
an expected sequence of moves
here's a fairly simple example blacks
upon a head and he thought since I'm up
a pawn I might as well trade a pair of
Knights the sequence that he thought was
going to happen was I'll take the knight
he takes my knight and everything is
cool just made an even trade
however after taking this Knight
something unfortunate happens we have a
fantastic killer sufficient ugh
Queen to e8 check
don't forget fishin Zhuge means
in-between move so instead of taking we
throw an in-between move at the guy hits
him with check he has to move his king
out of the way Queen takes h5 check he
still has to move his king out of the
way and then now we take and suddenly
yes that Knight takes c3 move that he
anticipated happen but in between you've
lost your other night and you're a goner
here's a more complex example here we
have a position from the game salve
elite Arctic our who was a very strong
grandmaster vs the reigning world
champion at the time jose Capablanca in
the very legendary
1924 tournament from new york white
thought the world champion who was black
had made a serious mistake here
he noticed that if he had played Queen
a4 check the bishops hanging however
black would simply get out of check and
guard the bishop at the same time bye
knight c6 so the logic was well what if
I just get rid of this Knight first and
when he recaptures then I'll do that
Queen check and the knight can't protect
the bishop and I win I beat the world
champion well that sounds pretty nice so
he went for it
Bishop takes b8 but of course being the
world champion Capablanca had seen this
and he throws in as visions
he plays Knight to d5 now with this one
move he's guarded this bishop and on top
of that he threatens a horrendous fork
Knight III check hitting the Queen and
the king
so after this move
poor old tark de Cour shrugging his
shoulders and realizing that he just
totally screwed it up played King F to
stopping this fork here and now
capablanca simply retook the bishop
safely and queen a4 check doesn't do
anything because now the bishops
protected and in this position it's a
big advantage for black just because
blacks King is going to Castle White's
King can't and in the end Capablanca
went on to win the game we went over a
lot of material but I don't expect you
to have mastered this stuff in chess
it's all about repetition the more you
see a particular pattern the better your
understanding of it will be but any
endeavor demands a first step and we've
taken that step here you'll see all
these patterns repeated throughout this
course and even if it's not the focus of
a particular lecture I'll point it out
when it happens and each time you see it
in action
the concept will sink a bit deeper into
your skin I also want to warn you that
there are a lot of names for every look
twitch and thought in chess this is
often nonsense and I'll do my best to
keep things simple for example I'm
mixing up decoy and deflection and
making them the same thing and one very
strong professional player I know is
tossed away the skewer and just calls it
a pin which is perfectly reasonable
remember that the point of us learning
these things is not to memorize their
names it's to memorize get comfortable
with and fully understand the patterns
every player who doesn't want to be a
punching bag eventually masters all
these tactical patterns why because
they're fun to use and they constantly
turn up they are literally ever
everywhere in every game sometimes
they'll become a reality and you'll
crush some guy with a monster for
sometimes you'll use your technical
knowledge to avoid your opponent's nasty
double attack and sometimes quite often
actually you'll have to decide whether
or not to allow a pin is that pin just a
tiny bother or is it going to Club you
over the head understanding these
patterns is your first big step towards
coming out on top